when did it occur to you that this is
what I need to do that like when did
you're like I know what I want to do
and I want to move to Africa and I want
to do this I mean whatever it is when
did that happen and and you know
so when I when I did American Pie it was
the first time I was in a position to
give back and long story short I just
realized I wanted to start my own animal
rescue so I started a dogging hat rescue
called animal Avengers ran it that way
for over 10 years and then knew I wanted
to help more animals on a bigger scale
and went on this long quest to figure
out what that was I didn't know how to
revamp the charity but I wanted to do
something else with it
and through my own process of figuring
myself out
um I was I had sold my house in La I was
looking for another place and then just
realized I didn't want to be in La
anymore went to New York and when I was
in New York I started somehow paying a
lot of attention to conservation
organizations
and there was a an ivory and Rhino Horn
uh Crush in Times Square that I got
invited to and I met a bunch of
conservationists there
and started following everyone online
and there was one video that I came
across like literally I was getting
ready to go to dinner I was doing my
makeup and something said check
Instagram
and I didn't know what I was checking
for but I was scrolling on Instagram and
I came across this video of an elephant
that had been poached and the ranger was
filming as he was walking and saying
this poor baby's been out here all night
suffering and as you see you saw her
trunk off to one side and then you saw
her face and then she moved
and that hit me like a ton of bricks the
fact that she was still alive
and this had happened to her and I never
till that moment realize that these
animals were getting
their their Ivory and their horns taken
off while they were alive and they were
feeling every cut
and that that's what changed it for me
and that was that was
2014 going into 2015. didn't you
Jesus just you explaining that to me I
just like felt it
it changed me I I the whole night I was
thinking about I was trying not to cry
at dinner I I couldn't get out of my
mind and I said that's what I want to do
with the charity the fact that these
animals these big Majestic animals like
elephants could go extinct in our
lifetime and we're we're here doing
nothing like it doesn't make sense like
we all got to go see an elephant or a
rhino at some point maybe when we were
younger or anywhere
you know that they're on the planet with
you but then to leave the planet one day
and they're not there anymore that's
that that didn't compute with me so I
started going to South Africa to learn
and to understand what the issue was and
try to find ways I could help and make a
difference and
in the process just decided I was going
to move here and spend more time here
and and uh I ended up getting married
and we revamped the charity to be the
Chan Elizabeth foundation for now it'll
change eventually soon hopefully
um but now we we have a blind black
rhino that we take care of we just built
a sanctuary forum
yeah and uh we're gonna bring some
females over so he can breed he's
already he's already doing this thing
where I've realized that he's checking
for female pheromones to see if they're
around
so I know he's ready for it and and
we're filming it all to be a docu-series
so
at this point we we just we need more
funding we need to up the security to
bring the females over we we have more
parts of the sanctuary we need to do and
we're talking to different broadcast
partners for the
for the docusary so it's the the first
time I'm really bringing my two worlds
together and
um I'm I'm directing it but I'm gonna
co-direct it I'm actually
I I'm actually looking for the right
co-director to do the rest of it with me
I have some ideas so